water is the liquid of life we drink it
we bathe in it we farm cook and clean
with it it's the most abundant molecule
in our bodies in fact every life-form we
know of would die without it but most
importantly without water we wouldn't
have iced tea hmm
iced tea
why do these ice cubes float if these
were cubes of solid argon in a cup of
liquid argon they would sink and the
same goes for most other substances but
solid water
aka ice is somehow less dense than
liquid water how's that possible
you already know that every water
molecule is made up of two hydrogen
atoms bonded to one oxygen atom let's
look at a few of the molecules in a drop
of water and let's say the temperature
is 25 degrees Celsius the molecules are
bending stretching spinning and moving
through space
now let's lower the temperature which
will reduce the amount of kinetic energy
each of these molecules has so they'll
Bend stretch spin and move less and that
means that on average they'll take up
less space now you'd think that as the
liquid water starts to freeze the
molecules would just pack together more
and more closely but that's not what
happens water has a special kind of
interaction between molecules that most
other substances don't have and it's
called a hydrogen bond now remember that
in a covalent bond two electrons are
shared usually unequally between atoms
in a hydrogen bond a hydrogen atom is
shared also unequally between atoms one
hydrogen bond looks like this to look
like this here's 3 & 4 & 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
I could go on in a single drop of water
hydrogen bonds form extended networks
between hundreds thousands millions
billions trillions of molecules and
these bonds are constantly breaking and
reforming now back to our water as it
cools down above 4 degrees Celsius the
kinetic energy of the water molecules
keeps their interactions with each other
short hydrogen bonds form and break like
highschool relationships that is to say
quickly but below 4 degrees the kinetic
energy of the water molecule starts to
fall below the energy of the hydrogen
bonds so hydrogen bonds form much more
frequently than they break and beautiful
structures start to emerge from the
chaos this is what solid water ice looks
like on the molecular
level notice that the ordered hexagonal
structure is less dense than the
disordered structure of liquid water and
you know that if an object is less dense
than the fluid its in it will float so
ice floats on water so what well let's
consider a world without floating ice
the coldest part of the ocean would be
the pitch-black ocean floor once frozen
always frozen forget lobster roll since
crustaceans would lose their habitats or
sushi since kelp forests wouldn't grow
what would Canadian kids do in winter
without pond hockey or ice fishing and
forget James Cameron's Oscar because the
Titanic totally would have made it say
goodbye to the white polar ice caps
reflecting sunlight that would otherwise
bake the planet in fact forget the
oceans as we know them which at over 70%
of the Earth's surface area regulate the
atmosphere of the whole planet but worst
of all there would be no ice tea mmm ice
tea
you